[Applaus]
hey leute ich habe wieder meine scheibe
aufgebaut ich habe mich dem kommentar
gelesen dass ich das noch mal machen
sollte und ich habe gerade sozusagen
ferien habe eine menge zeit und jetzt
wird ein feuer geworfen der die nächsten
tag entscheiden wird ich habe keine
karte ausgedruckt von europa wir haben
eigentlich jedes europäische land
russland ist nicht ganz drauf aber der
nächste teil entscheidet über meine
weise ziel ich hoffe es ist irgendwas wo
ich noch nie war oder zumindest
irgendwas interessant ich werde heute
blind weil die distanz ist nicht
wirklich groß und ja das gibt es doch
gar nicht ja leute hier sieht man es
irgendwo zwischen dänemark und schweden
also wenn ich so drauf gucke ist das
also die nächste stadt ist kopenhagen
kam eigentlich gedacht hoffentlich
irgendwie in die sonne oder so aber
jesus extrem warm deswegen ich gucke
einfach mal ob das klappt und was meine
freunde zu sagen weil ich wollte noch
ein paar mitnehmen wirklichkeit
ich freue mich das ziel war also die
hauptstadt von dänemark kopenhagen ich
persönlich war vorher noch nie irgendwie
nördlich von deutschland unterwegs und
hatte keine ahnung wie es da so aussieht
natürlich hatte man so ein bild durch
fotos und videos ich konnte noch drei
freund überreden mitzukommen wir waren
also zu viert hatten gerade ziemlich
viel freizeit oder ich habe auch noch
viel freizeit und ja keiner von uns
bisher dort gewesen wir hatten also
keine ahnung was uns erwartet und das
hier ist ein blog vom ganzen trip ich
wünsche euch viel spaß wenn ihr sagt
herr alex megacool idee macht das doch
bitte noch mal dann gibt auf jeden fall
mal daumen nach oben denn ich habe wie
gesagt noch ein bisschen freizeit jetzt
die nächsten eineinhalb monate und dann
schauen wir mal
oder nicht so frei landet
[Musik]
jetzt ist aber auch schon fall dann
kommt das nach oben drauf kommen zu
einem neuen video christian guten morgen
heute geht es für uns nach dänemark und
die christian ist auch dabei ich bin der
fahrer
ich habe nämlich noch keinen
führerschein wir haben uns ein geiles
auto ausgeliehen gefahren nämlich nicht
mit meinem oder mit irgendeinem von
unseren autos ich habe auch immer klar
hier noch gar nicht drin und zwar mir
von vw einen touran bekommen der ist
eigentlich brandneu ich glaube 2000
kilometer gelaufen sie doch wirklich
schön aus wie sehe ich ein haus aber
leute wie schon gesagt oder wie es sich
ergeben hat wir fahren heute nach
dänemark ich war noch nie in denen war
ich habe ja schon gesagt eigentlich
könnten wir auch fliegen aber mit dem
auto ist es viel günstiger
deswegen fahren wir mit dem bus tram mit
drin
jetzt geht es erst mal sechs stunden
oder so bis an die nordsee hast sie dann
mit der fähre weiter und irgendwann
heute abend sind wir hoffentlich da oder
auch nicht ganz wichtig noch bevor es
losgeht und zwar ist in der video
beschreibung ein video verlinkt von kopp
tv wir von kiwi team haben ein cooles
video zusammengestellt und zwar zb mein
part war es witze am stiel zu backen
oder zu kochen wie man es nennen will
man kann einige coole sachen gewinnen
wie zum beispiel den versuch im sterne
restaurant in meinem fall also ganz oben
die beschreibung verlinkt schaut vorbei
koch tv und jetzt geht es weiter mit dem
video
[Musik]
so leute ich bin jetzt hier auf einem
boot wir sind heute morgen um 9 uhr
losgefahren werden jetzt 18 37 das heißt
wir sind schon wirklich neun stunden
unterwegs
und wir müssen auch noch zwei das heißt
wir haben für 700 kilometer insgesamt
zwölf stunden gebraucht am ende
ich melde mich
[Musik]
zurück in unserem ferrari gegen sie
laufen lassen
das ist ein typisch dänisch zuerst und
gibt so den kuchen
das licht ist hier kommt das möchte ist
hier richtig gut das ist ja ein guck mal
hübsch einmal
wir müssen jetzt noch 160 kilometer
fahren oder anderen wir in kopenhagen
kopenhagen ist direkt neben jetzt hoffen
wir mal kommen wir durch
hallo es sieht gut aus ja wir sind da
wir sind durch drogen habt ihr nicht
gefunden hätte jetzt gleich kommt hier
einfach so einen wohnwagen ich hab an
diesen kranken wohnwagen gesehen passt
sicher delek apokalypse
[Musik]
so leute wir sind jetzt hier angekommen
kopenhagen jetzt sieht auf jeden fall
echt schön aus große häuser nur hier ist
fast niemand also hier fahren kaum autos
vielleicht haben wir schon später als
bei uns und die sonne geht hier nicht
unter wie beim nord bei den nordlichtern
das ist ein heftiges hotel
ich habe mir das wirklich ganz anders
vorgestellt ich dachte ihr schmerzen so
dass leute wir sind endlich da nach zehn
stunden
wir haben eine echte entspannte wohnung
für ja gerade vier leute hier ist die
toilette aber dieses gerade besetzt
wir haben wir eine wunderschöne küche
typisch dänisch eingerichtet christian
macht gerade mein sofa für heute finde
ich richtig nett von dir danke also wir
ungefähr so 20 quadratmeter die aussicht
ist jetzt nicht so geil aber gibt es ja
auch nicht irgendwo wir haben sogar ein
ventilator ja und hier ist wirklich vor
das ist echt gut dass ein doppelbett und
so sieht das was ich wirklich cool fand
es ist hier alles extrem modern jetzt in
dieser siedlung hier ist nicht unbedingt
so modern aber wenn man mal so nach
dahinter schaut die gebäude die aus
ihren was hast du gesagt amerikaner
ich war da und deswegen kann ich das
nicht weiß also nie finanzen sind und
die häuser relativ hoch sind ja also
werden wir zu viert
dieses kleine appartement das sind
locker 50 quadratmetern maximal oder
aber es lässt sich hier auf jeden fall
aushalten genau also wir sind da ich
freue mich wirklich sehr spontan und
cool und heute abend gibt's natürlich
auch die city wir haben alle frei und
freuen uns dass wir in dänemark sinnwell
waren hier noch nie ihr könnt ja gerne
mal schreiben ob ihr schon mal hier mal
da hinten ist im flugzeug
wir hätten auch fliegen können aber auto
war irgendwie günstiger und die
landschaften die man auch extrem cool
als das heißt wir auf jeden fall gelohnt
dann morgen christian ein kleines
resümee von gestern nacht alles richtig
gemacht mit vier stunden schlaf
jedes jetzt nur strand wir waren heute
um 3 uhr zu hause und es war so heiß die
sonne hat hier so ein ball hat dann
könnte man auch irgendwie gar nicht
verschlafen so jetzt nehme ich hier noch
eine banane mit und auf geht's
da kommt schon unser flitzer heimat zum
strand würde den sportmodus rein so ich
bin jetzt mal die andere seite schneller
-bitte wann de bietet zwei meter
unbedingt hier runter da hinten noch
einer
übrigens nach miami
lediglich sehr tolle brücke lidl hier
very good vier euro für donuts sieben
euro für käse baguette die überschrift
tolles land der welt gibt es so eine
andere währung als in deutschland guckt
mal rechtschreibfehler normalerweise
heißt ja nur billig billig billig billig
ihre pisten nuggets und hat auch den
richtigen 31
so jetzt wollen wir gerade fast
abgeschleppt aber wir sind noch genau
passend wieder von dem einen typen der
lange telefoniert hat die wohnung müssen
wir unsere schulden machen heute abend
formationen soll heute geht es doch mal
so wir fahren jetzt gerade über eine wie
lange sie bröker 88 kilometer lange
brücke die längst das ist die längste
brücke in europa kann das sein
und die brücke verbindet halt schweden
mit dänemark davon ist ein windpark mit
dem wasser
[Musik]
so wir sind jetzt im himmel und versuche
erst mal ein ticket zu ziehen
aber es schwieriger als gedacht michael
aßmann tretbootfahren sowie waren jetzt
in miami unterwegs ist auf jeden fall
eine sehr schöne stadt wobei ich finde
kommen ist schön weil wir haben schon
wieder 25 grad von ein bisschen
abkühlung tut natürlich bei dem wetter
gute jungs hier ist unser auto gesehen
einfach genau gleich aus dem sogar die
gleichen felgen wir haben ja das
enthielten verloren
dann müssen wir zu ängstlich aber ein
alter kenne ich gar nicht da hinten kann
man einfach unter
[Musik]
soweit für guten morgen nach vier tagen
gewannen ist vier tage hier waren wir
wieder wir haben gerade das bett schon
sauber gemacht und haben wir nicht allzu
viel schlaf also das war hier so eine
airbnb wollen
jetzt geht es ungefähr sieben stunden
bis nach deutschland mit dem schiff und
wir haben in deutschland einfach 37 grad
auf jeden fall ganz cool hier mal so nur
25 grad zu haben
ende thema oh ja ich könnte auch
flugzeug sein wir haben einfach einen
steinschlag im auto ich habe noch nie in
meinem leben den steinschlag kassiert
der am fenster und vor allem der das gar
nicht mal so klein 39 grad
sehr gut jetzt für unser auto wieder
sauber gemacht und dann war's das
christian hier musst du noch so leute
herzlich willkommen nehmen was wir uns
herzlich willkommen
ich bin jetzt schon wieder zu hause das
video ist komplett fertig geschnitten
wenn ihr euch fragt was das hier ist ich
muss gar so einen test machen also also
nichts wildes nur dass es so warm und
ich muss aufpassen dass die dinger dran
bleiben weil wenn ich dieser tage ist es
ziemlich witzig und dann geht das sieht
schlimmer aus als es ist auf jeden fall
wollte ich noch sagen dänemark so
zusammengefasst war wirklich mega cool
vor allem kopenhagen als stadt war
richtig geil
und was immer total lustig die leute
sind meiner meinung nach zum teil viel
offener als hier und auch viel
freundlicher mann wird irgendwie selber
angesprochen und in deutschland kann ich
das jetzt nicht so extrem
ja ich werde angesprochen aber nicht in
dem sinne euro wollte vielleicht was von
meinen getränk haben oder soweit also es
war mega cool war eine richtig geile
erfahrung sehr sehr gerne wieder
kopenhagen kann man auf jeden fall
machen hat richtig spaß gemacht es gerne
doch nach oben da wenn es euch gefallen
hat der stadt ziemlich lange gedauert
ich hoffe das sieht man auch und wenn er
sagt macht das doch bitte noch mal mit
einem anderen fall und gucken muss dann
hingeht schreibt in den kommentaren
lässt noch nach oben da wir sehen uns
checks oder instagram ab 3 danke fürs zu
sehen und ich verbringen jetzt noch 20
stunden mit diesem teil geil